one single Magic the Gathering card
recently sold for 2.6 million dollars
the question is
[Music]
guys this is a big day for me after five
years working at the score Esports I
finally get to make a video about my
favorite game a game that I've spent
years of my life traveling all over
North America to play Magic the
Gathering the reason well rapper post
Malone recently purchased a single Magic
card for 2.6 million dollars right in my
backyard Whitby Ontario Canada and I'm
sure you've already seen that headline
in fact you may have seen it right here
on this YouTube channel remember that
one magic card that everyone really
wanted well this dude found it at its
height offers to buy the One of a Kind
one ring card reached over two million
dollars so when Brooke trafton the lucky
guy who actually found it finally got it
authenticated he sold it to post Malone
the question is how could a single card
cost that much money well let's get
nerdy during the pandemic Collectibles
absolutely exploded in popularity and in
price people were inside they had a bit
more money to spend not commuting to
work every day and a whole lot more time
to spend being obsessed with their new
hobbies magic being one of those I'm
sure many of you saw guys like moist
critical cracking packs of Pokemon cards
Logan Paul flexing his truly insane
Pikachu illustrator necklace and the
ludicrous money people were spending on
sports cards and sneakers well magic
cards are really not all that different
than sneakers in this case I would know
because I'm addicted to both of them as
someone who's played magic seriously for
more than 10 years I can personally
attest to just how much more expensive
the game has become since the beginning
of the pandemic and if you want evidence
I've got some graphs for you
black lotus one of the game's oldest and
most expensive cards has spiked to like
fifty thousand dollars and post Malone
also bought a very rare one of those for
800 Grand we go look at Magic the
Gathering cards what is the highest
amount of money you ever paid for a
magic the Gathering card eight hundred
thousand dollars even less rare but more
often played cards like say polluted
Delta and eternal format Staple in the
game jumped over a hundred percent
during the collectible search so you've
got this world of collecting that's
underwent this huge Boot and cards are
selling for like 50 Grand but that's a
far cry from over 2 million dollars this
this is where we enter the world of
collaborations one that you Esports and
gaming fans will be very familiar with
you see much like sneakers and well
actually Esports orgs for that matter
magic the Gathering has gone hard on
collabs recently much to the frustration
of many of the game's most entrenched
competitive players somewhere between
the release of their newest digital
platform MTG Arena the Collectibles boom
that I've been talking about during the
pandemic and the soaring popularity of
one of the game's casual formats
Commander Wizards of the Coast and their
parent company Hasbro said damn
we collab with other popular games and
IPS we can basically print money so now
we have a magic dungeon dragon set
Street Fighter cards fortnite cards the
list goes on and one of the latest in
this long line of Ip crossovers is Lord
of the Rings Tales of Middle Earth a
full set of magic cards set in The Lord
of the Rings world and before we go any
further I just want to make sure that
everybody understands I am not being a
hater a lot of these collabs are really
cool Commander is definitely really
cool it's just when you're
collaborating with a new IP every week
it can be a little bit exhausting for an
entrenched player like myself now with
the release of this new set Lord of the
Rings Tales of Middle Earth came the one
rant magic came to us with this one of
one the one ring card in my head I was
just thinking yes yeah that that makes
sense that tracks that's obviously yes
we took the one ring and we created a
serialized one-of-one version this is
the only copy of the one of one ring
that's ever going to exist and to
translate that what that means is that
there is exactly one physical copy of
that version of this card in the entire
world in one English collector booster
pack and that fact combined with the
pandemic boom combined with the fact
that people like me love this game
combined with the fact that it's the
one ring to rule them all got
people pretty stoked my personal Twitter
timeline was blowing up and within hours
of the announcement vendors and
collectors were offering hundreds of
thousands of dollars for the card Flash
Forward a couple weeks ago and the card
was found open and sold to post Malone
in what has to be one of the most
wholesome moments in the history of
magic and if you're wondering what
someone does when they pull 2.6 million
dollars out of a random pack of magic
cards well the answer is equally
wholesome the dude that pulled it bro
Brook trafton posted a thread on Twitter
explaining what he plans to do with the
cash and the bow on top of all of this
is that the one ring not the fancy
version that he opened but the card
itself that you can get in a regular
booster pack is one of the best cards in
the entire game right now it was the
most popularly played card in the recent
Pro Tour in Barcelona in the modern
format one of the most powerful in the
entire game so not only is this card
Making Waves all over mainstream media
but much like the artifact that inspired
it
it's pretty broken
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock
foreign